wasn't it like the [ __ ] in in england
what like the 5g
towers caused that was embarrassing that
was like
whatever it was that was like huge in
the uk yeah that people were like
burning down these towers yeah it's
embarrassing you're like
these are like i live in the same
country these people i went to the same
schools
yeah there's these people who burned
down [ __ ] 5g towns there's also that
fat of like you know
you should you shouldn't like when when
foot where wireless uh like bluetooth
headphones first came out for your phone
like people should use those because if
you if you're on the phone like
this then the signal actually i remember
that yeah i remember
yeah and there were people at least in
australia like when i was growing up
there were like people dead ass being
like [ __ ] i have to go and buy some
bluetooth headphones you know
i don't want i don't want to get a tumor
in my brain from all these phone calls
i'm taking i'm like
what are you on i think one of the most
interest
uh interesting things i've like i've
seen happen recently that's happened
right in front of my eyes is the [ __ ]
toilet paper shortage
right like like i think back to that and
like what does that feel like 10 years
ago i know
but like i think back to that and like
our kids are going to be reading about
this or like they're going to see like
it's next
they're going to see the internet
historian video like [ __ ]
20 years in the future and be thinking
like ha my generation we're never this
stupid
it's like i'm just imagining like you
know 20 years from now like our kids
right
we'll be like in [ __ ] history class
like modern history being like yeah all
right it's class so today we're going to
be talking about the 2020 great toilet
paper
shortage like it's the same as the
[ __ ] great depression it blew my mind
how in japan it happened as well i'm
like we literally have [ __ ] bidets
it blew my mind that it happened
worldwide this was it was literally like
a
idea that spread worldwide even though
like nobody
nobody knew where it came from oh no no
no no no it's the fans
the thing is nobody like in other
countries really knew that it came from
australia because they were just like
oh toilet paper i must buy i'm not i
don't know why but everyone else is
buying toilet paper therefore i must buy
toilet paper
it didn't occur to people that maybe
like you know if everyone just keeps
using toilet paper at the same rate that
we've all been using it
it'll continue to be the same right like
i don't know why because it was out of
every household necessity that you think
would happen
that you think people would need an
apocalypse food water
i sleep toilet paper i wake yeah this is
the real [ __ ]
so what do people think that like if you
got covered you also got irritable bowel
syndrome like
in my mind as well i'm like do i really
want to be an [ __ ] who just goes and
like
[ __ ] takes everything in the shop i'm
like ah i mean i'll i'll take like a
little bit of like pasta a little bit of
canned goods yeah something crazy
yeah i mean you know like we like we
stocked up yeah but we didn't [ __ ]
like be like
can i have everything on that shelf from
there to there no we we
we only stocked up just because there
was a literal shortage and there was a
little point where
i had trouble wiping my ass because
there wasn't there was no toilet paper i
mean like
you know i was i was going to clean my
ass with a bidet but i wasn't going to
step out with a weird ass all right like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] i just jiggle you know
a little shake because you know it was
the one piece of
like everyday household equipment there
you know you can understand soap you
know okay i understand if there would be
a
shortage of soap i can understand hand
sanitizer
of course i understand why there would
be food and water food and water yeah
there wasn't
any i'm like do you know how easy it is
to loaf like rice or pasta like you
don't need much of that but there was
even a shortage of like pasta as well
like i
remember yeah yeah they're actually i
remember i remember the video of uh i
think it was in italy
there there was like all of this
supermarkets yeah they're like all guys
and the old guy was like getting pissed
off that there was no pasta in the
supermarket and he was like
people weren't even this obsessed during
world war two
we had more pastor in world war ii than
we do now what the [ __ ] going on
yeah i guess the problem is that like
everyone's telling each other you should
panic like in real time right spread it
yeah it's like oh my god
i don't know i had a bunch of cup ramen
and i was like i'm pretty i think i'm
good
yeah i'll see what happens like i'm
pretty sure the stores aren't just gonna
shut
yeah i i like there would be an exact
point
where i would like start panicking and
that exact point
is if i found out the kombini was closed
because like i feel like
here if the combination closes you're
going through some real [ __ ] that is
when i'm truly watching
okay are we really going through an
apocalypse okay i wake now
i'm [ __ ] yeah it's like america
they're like waffle house and like you
can judge on like the disaster based on
whether
waffle house is open or closed it's like
it's an actual like study like
thing where like even when there's like
hurricanes
waffle house in america is still open
wow
seriously yeah seriously look it up it's
really interesting like i think i
don't know which big natural disaster it
was i think it was like katrina or
something like yeah
it was still open like because
because they're all equipped with like
generators right why
in case disasters yeah they're like one
of the only things that like will try
their best to stay open unless like
you know the disaster is so bad yeah
when waffle house in america
like damn my roof just got blown off i
could kill for some waffles right now
if like windows and [ __ ] are broken i
think they'll still continue to be open
like they'll let you in
like i i i'm not i'm not sure exactly i
could be chatting out my ass but
it's as far as i've been because i i
think what
this entire situation has made me
realize is i i remember like
oh before before 2020 watching like old
school
zombie movies and something like that
and you think to yourself man they made
the they made the people really stupid
in this
zombie movie this would never happen in
real life and now i look back and i'm
just
like definitely gonna happen i'm like
they didn't make themselves stupid
enough jesus christ
there'll be a sect of people that like
rounds up people and feeds them to the
zombies because if they think it'll
probably appease the zombie or something
[ __ ] like that there'll be something
like that i look at something like dead
rising and i'm like well this is
unrealistic there's still things inside
all of the stores the toilet paper is
still a little bit what the [ __ ]
there isn't a subgroup of people
praising the zombies what's going on